accessing funding building a support
network those are just two of the
challenges that women business owners
face here in the valley right now the
pandemic even more difficult mary jane
billy isn't joining us now live at one
of those businesses it's a keto bakery
starburst parlor on charleston and
rancho
and mary jane i know you've been working
hard enjoying probably all the wonderful
smells there in the bakery but there is
resources available for our community so
talk about that with us
oh yeah heather and john absolutely it
hasn't been easy especially for owner
jill schlesinger who is here with me
joining us brian earley thank you so
much jill we talked a lot about those
challenges that women business owners
have faced especially yourself with
accessing funds and making sure that
people were taking your business
seriously but you're also facing another
set of problems too and that includes
shipping costs due to inflation we ship
nationwide so coast to coast we ship
cookies
bagels and just depending on the heat
what's going on but lately the shipping
is taking so long and the costs are so
high that it hinders me from expanding
my business because the shipping costs
are so high and it's taking so long oh
my gosh that must be really tough
especially for quality control and i
know the good part is there is some help
in the community i know we were talking
a lot about grants and funds and that's
really helpful for businesses like yours
oh definitely it's it's just helped in
so many ways and
and just collaborating with other women
in the community means so much because i
could only learn more from everyone's
experience and hopefully just grow in
that way oh that's perfect of course
we're here we have to finish making our
cookies i'm not sonya to help me out
here because i know that we have been
cracking eggs all morning and now we're
gonna make them into balls here and
hopefully put them in the oven and so we
have already made a really nice batch
right you've done an amazing job these
look so perfect it was kind of nice i
got to get a nice scoop here i think i'm
going to call you on the weekends to
help you when i have so many orders
well the nice part is it not only smells
good but it's kind of tempting to want
to eat and so we're going to be here of
course for the rest of the morning
trying to put all of this on the tray
and bake them so you'll have to stay in
tune for that as well reporting live
mary jane belliesa live local now
cookie dough